no it's definitely not adequate for all
the things that need to be done to fix
this problem but it goes a long way it
gives us hope this settlement gives us
hope that we'll be able to make
significant impact on the issues that we
face and what made this different than
the national proposal was these two
counties will get money now to address
the problem now because when people
decide they need help we need to get
them help immediately and this is going
to give summit in Cuyahoga County the
opportunity to do just that 50 will be
now and then we went through the
breakdown on the tab of money
previously it'll be 5 million before the
end of the year 5 million first quarter
next year 5 million first quarter 2021
and 5 million second quarter 2021 now
keep in mind it's for two counties when
you say now we yesterday hope it's cat
we passed so we have to work through the
details of the agreement but the
expectation is that it will be paid in
the very near future it is not a
settlement that allows for payment over
many years
that was the problem with the national
settlement that was proposed they were
talking billions of dollars paid in
trickles not even enough startup money
to help any any one County start its
program and that's why we couldn't
recommend to the county that that was a
good deal for the county or anyone else
and we had to stand alone and say no to
the national settlement and now they
have to come back to the table to fix
that we need money up front for all the
cities and all the counties and then you
pay out more money over time
the national settlement we would not
this year have gotten more than we would
have gotten less than a million dollars
under the national proposal which was
not enough to do anything I believe that
there's still hundreds of cases
thousands of cases that are standing out
there that will be either tried or
settle and I believe that the bellwether
lawsuits the bellwether settlement
should set a standard for all of the
cities and counties and states around
the country how long
hopefully not long this is a national
emergency right now in all counties or
municipalities all villages need help
right now
to combat this crisis